à une réaction tout d'abord à la
réélection de Gérard lincher au plateau
ce n'est pas une surprise mais qu'est-ce
que ça vous évoque vous cette réélection
comme vous le dites ce n'est pas du tout
du tout une surprise
et ce qui est encore moins une surprise
c'est de voir que de constater que
l'élection de arraché à uni beaucoup
plus de suffrage que sa majorité que la
majorité sénatoriale c'est-à-dire que sa
personnalité
son sens du dialogue de l'écoute avec
l'ensemble des sénateurs et salué par
cette élection qui est une élection tout
à fait confortable le groupe que vous
présidez les indépendants République et
territoire le groupe de la droite Macron
compatible ainsi que le groupe RDPI le
groupe Renaissance au Sénat non pas
présenté de candidat face à un marché
pourquoi quand les choses ne marchent
bien il y a pas de raison de les réparer
et par conséquent genre l'archet est un
très bon Président du Sénat
c'est il est dans l'opposition au
gouvernement mais dans une opposition
constructive on le voit encore plus
depuis que l'Assemblée nationale est
dans la situation de blocage aujourd'hui
le Sénat est une opposition raisonnée
qui dialogue avec le gouvernement c'est
d'ailleurs ce que j'ai remarché a dit
dans son discours et dans ces conditions
pourquoi lui opposer qui que ce soit
alors d'ici demain on devrait connaître
la composition exacte des groupes
politiques on aura le nombre de chaque
groupe politique combien de sénateurs
partiel est-ce que vous êtes en mesure
de donner votre nombre de sénateurs vous
nous sommes un peu moins de 20 sénateurs
mais comme tout peut changer jusqu'au
dernier moment j'ai pas le chiffre exact
mais on est passé de 14 sénateurs à
quelque chose entre 18 et 20 est-ce que
ça dit quelque chose de ce qui se joue
au Sénat un sénat plus au centre avec 10
LR en moins par exemple au groupe les
républicains ça dit quelque chose même
très lentement même à la marge de ce qui
se joue au Sénat je suis pas sûr qu'on
puisse parler de
façon géographique comme vous le faites
moi pour moi c'est un succès des
indépendants et d'horizons puisque
beaucoup des sénateurs qui qui
rejoignent notre groupe aujourd'hui
sont des scénario horizon ça témoigne de
l'implantation d'horizon dans les
communes puisque c'est une implantation
territoriale qui fait qui qui vote pour
les sénateurs ce sont des des élus des
territoires et c'est pour moi le succès
comme à l'Assemblée nationale il y a un
an de l'implantation
d'horizon dans les territoires et dans
les communes et d'Édouard Philippe aussi
vous le dites ben quand je dis horizon
jeudi Édouard Philippe bien entendu
[Musique]